back everyone
so today we're going to start lecture
number 15
and the topic for today is basically uh
what's left of reinforcement learning
for the purposes of this course
we're going to wrap up our reinforcement
learning today so
first we're going to discuss
learnt models we're going to do this
first and then then
talk about extensions of the methods
we've seen to
continuous state settings and we're
going to cover two
topics over there discretization and
fitted value function or iteration
and once we are done with these two that
basically marks the end of
what's part of the syllabus for this
course the parts that you'll be tested
on
and for the rest of the lecture once we
are done with this we will do a quick
survey
of the larger reinforcement field
reinforcement learning field in general
just talk about the different kinds of
uh approaches that
that are there in reinforcement learning
that we are not covering
and kind of give you an approximate mind
map of how to kind of
relate all the different concepts in rl
uh to each other
right so before we jump into today's
topics let's do a quick review of what
was
covered on the previous class on
wednesday so we started off with
a formalism called markov decision
processes where this formalism
describes the setting in which there is
an agent that is making sequential
decisions over time
and an mdp or a markov decision process
is a tuple of five entities so first is
a set of states set of all possible
states that the agent can
currently be in a is the set of all
actions that an agent can take for
simplicity we will assume that
all actions can be taken in all states
psa
is what is called as the transition
probabilities so transition
probabilities
is we have a set of transition
probabilities for
the set of all states and the set of all
actions
what that specifically means is the pro
the transition probability is uh each
psa is a probability distribution over
the set of states
and it is different for every every
combination of s and a so if we are in
current state s
and we take current action a then the
state that we will
end up in for the next time step is
distributed according to p
s a right so this is only describing
how the world works right think of this
as like the laws of physics you take an
action
and you end up in some states this is
how the world works right
and gamma is uh what we call as a
discount factor it's a value between 0
and 1
and r is it's a function it can either
be a function of state
or a function of a state an action pair
and it is the
immediate reward function what is the
immediate reward that we get
for being in a particular state right
and there are
these two central concepts in
reinforcement learning that's beyond the
mdp formalism
called the policy and the value right
these these two are kind of you can you
can you can you know in a loose sense
you can think of
them as the duals of each other right so
the policy
basically is is the rule book that the
agent follows
right it tells us when we are in the
current state s what is the action that
we need to take
and the action that we take based on the
policy will decide
which new new state will end up in based
on the transition probabilities
right so the policy is is just a rule
book of what action we need to take when
we are in a particular state
right and the value value function is
is like the long term accumulated
uh or the expected long term accumulated
reward
along with the discount factor gamma so
the v pi of s
is the expected sum of all rewards
that is the reward at current state plus
a discount
times the reward at the second state
plus a discount discount square times
the reward at the third state and so on
and it is the expected sum of these uh
future rewards discounted future reverse
assuming
we are starting at a state s naught
equal to the point where we are
evaluating the value function
and assuming we are taking you know we
are following some particular policy pi
right and this is also called the
bellman's equation
and this this expected sum of future
rewards
can be expressed this way according to
the bellman's equation
there was a question from some student
about how how we go from here to here
and there is a short derivation that i
posted on piazza number 240 if you want
to see how we went from here to here
it's pretty straight forward now there
was also a question of
uh gamma yesterday you know should it be
the same value should it be
less than 1 and so on the answer is it
should be less than 1
strictly less than 1 it cannot be
greater than 1 and
it is this gamma that is less than 1
that makes the value
function bounded right so um it's it's
easy to see
if supposing gamma was equal to one then
in general we could have accumulated uh
we can keep accumulating rewards by an
infinite amount
and in general the expectation need not
be bound so right the expected sum of
all future words can explode to infinity
but because we have this discount factor
gamma
which is mostly uh mostly here for
mathematical reasons just to make the
value function bounded but it also
happens that it has nice interpretations
such as you know the interest rate and
whatnot
if you're working in in um in an um
finance setting or you can think of it
as you know the rate at which your
um you know robots fuel is decreasing or
whatever so you can have different kinds
of
interpretations for gamma but it exists
mostly for
mathematical convenience to make the
value function bounded and the reason
why it's bounded is
is pretty pretty simple you can see that
you can this expectation is going to be
less than
you know um it's going to be
we can show a quick proof here so this
ah expected sum
of the words r of s 1 plus gamma times
you know so on will be less than
expectation of i'm just going to call it
r
star plus gamma times r star
plus gamma square times r star etc
where r star is the maximum possible
reward that you can get
in any possible state and once you have
this you can take r star common and you
get a one plus gamma plus gamma square
and so on
that is bounded so the expected sum of
all future rewards
will always be bounded if we use
a gamma of less than one
right and then
based on these these uh these two you
know central concepts
policy and value we can define something
called as the optimal value function so
the optimal value function
is the best possible long-term value we
can have
if we were to choose a suitable policy
so if we were to optimize over all the
possible policies that can exist
what is the best possible future
you know long term uh long term value
that we can come up with
right and this is uh similarly we can
see that v star s
is equal to uh can also be written as r
of s plus
uh max of a
of this term and you know you can you
can see that this is pretty intuitive
what this means is
v star of s is you know the the best
possible long term value
is equal to the sum of the current value
that we got you know that's that's
immutable the reward that we got at the
at the current step is the reward that
we got at the current step no matter
what our policy was
right and the
and and choose you know this is a
recursive definition
and choose an action such that we
maximize
the long term reward at the next time
step
right so depending on which action we
choose we get a different probability
distribution
for the future different transition
probability distribution
and take the expectation of the next
time step according to
the probability distribution so max is
basically
the the max operator is choosing
different
transition probabilities essentially
right choose an action such that
the resulting transition probabilities
will give you the highest expected
reward
uh expected uh future value at the next
time step right so it is this
this recursive definition um which also
happens to be called bellman's equation
confusingly
this is also called the bellman's
equation
and the corresponding to the value
the optimal value function there is this
implicit optimal policy
so the implicit optimal policy is any
such policy
that allows us to achieve the optimal
value function
right in in theory it is possible that
there exists
multiple policies so strictly speaking
uh this should be
element of the set of arc max because
this arg max
well so probably this should not be
element
yeah so this this uh should be uh an
element because there could be multiple
actions that you can take in any step
that gives you the optimal
um the uh that maximizes uh
the future value but for the purpose of
this course we'll assume that it is
unique
right and it is this optimal policy that
is is is kind of our you know uh that's
that's our end goal that's what we
strive to achieve
and when we say we want to solve an mdp
it means we want to find
the pi star the optimal policy that
you know in some way and that is called
solving an mdp
right and then we we saw the relation
between policy and value right the
policy and value are kind of
they have this intimate relationship
where given a
given given a policy pi there there is
a corresponding value function that you
achieve
by just following that policy all the
time right
and we saw we we saw this derivation
last time where
given a policy pi there is an associated
v
pi that can be derived in this way where
this is the identity function and p
pi is the transition uh transition
matrix
where for each state we choose the
corresponding p s a according
where the a is taken from uh pi and and
so
from from uh from pi we can
recover a v pi this way and this is
called policy evaluation
right that's one direction the other
direction where you are given a value
function
right and this value function induces a
policy
which is also called the greedy policy
with respect to v right and that policy
is basically
at any given state s choose the action
the the action that is prescribed by
this policy is basically the action
that maximizes the the
expected value of the next time step
where the value is defined by the given
value function
right so this we can we can we can go
between
policy to value and value to policy
using these two relations
right a subtle point to note
is that given a policy
we get we get a corresponding value
function that
ah that that is kind of associated with
this policy however a subtle point which
may not be obvious at
first sight is if we were to take
this policy pi that was induced
in this greedy way from this value
function right if
if we were to follow this policy the
resulting value that we get is not this
value function
it may be a different value function
right that's a subtle point a value
function
induces a policy but if we were to
follow this policy
it is not we will not get the same value
function we need not get the same value
function
right and that's a subtle point then
that's something that we're going to see
in
in policy iteration right and
we saw one algorithm of solving mdps
where
the first algorithm we saw was value
iteration now in value iteration
it is an iterative algorithm you know it
is called value iteration it is an
iterative algorithm
where we start at some arbitrary value
function it could be
the value function is equal to you can
either set it to all zeros or you can
initialize
it to the reward function itself you
start at some value function
right and we iterate it over and over
where we take the the value function of
the current iteration and run it through
something whether it's called the
bellman backup operator
right and we get the next value function
and then we plug it in and get the next
value function and so on
and the bellman value operator is this
defined in this way so the bellman
backup operator
is uh the the uh
you know if this is v pr v v
prime of s is equal to
where v prime is bellman operator on the
previous v
so the the the value function for the
next time step is equal to
r of s plus max of you know whatever
expression here
and this thing here is basically the
right hand side of the optimal value
function
right and this is called the bellman ah
backup operator
and we run this algorithm
in a loop and iteratively until we
converge
on a v a v function where v function
stops
stops changing and once we get that v
function we can recover
the corresponding policy using this
expression
so given a v that has converged through
value iteration recover a policy and
that's our
you know optimal policy that's our
solution to an mdp
and the reason why this converges we saw
that it is possible to show
that this bellman bellman backup
operator is what is called as a
contraction mapping
so if we imagine the space of functions
a functional space
where each point here defines a value
function
not a point here represents an entire
value function
where the coordinate of that
where each a coordinate along a
particular axis is the value of the
value function along that state
right and the bellman backup operator is
a contraction mapping which means
if we take any two value functions
run the two of them through the bellman
operator right the distance between the
outputs will be closer than the distance
between the inputs
right that's why it's called a
contraction mapping because as you run
as you apply points through
the bellman backup operator through this
contraction mapping they get closer and
closer
right and the point at which they
converge is called the fixed point of
that operator
and that fixed point is v star right
that v star is the optimal value
right um and then we saw this other
algorithm called policy iteration right
so this this
was this is one possible algorithm for
solving an mdp
this is another algorithm for solving an
mtp
and in this algorithm we basically
exploit the subtlety that i mentioned
earlier
that from a given pi we get a
corresponding v
where this v is is the value that you
get by following
uh the policy pi however there is a
way from which you know the the the
other other direction where we recover a
policy
by using the guidance of some value
function right we use this
value function estimate to choose a
particular policy to do
where we strive to do better uh where we
strive to do our best
given the current policy and using this
policy
if we actually use this policy the
resulting value function may be
different
right and that is the subtlety that we
make that we use over here
so start with some randomly initialized
policy so
random unit of pi
right and from this random
initialization of pi we
you know we do step one from for for a
given pie
we use uh uh we calculate the
corresponding value function
which is which is what we call as poly
policy evaluation
right and once we get the policy uh the
the corresponding policy v pi
we get you know we we try to
recover we try to calculate the optimal
policy
for this v pi right and we do this over
and over
until pi converges and this is called
policy iteration and the the converged
pi
will be pi star right and
and once we get pi star we can again
recover v star
and the pi star and v star that we get
from this algorithm and the pi star and
v star
we get from this algorithms are
essentially the same
right so this is this is how much we
covered
last in the last class any questions on
this before we jump into today's topics
right cool so today we are going to
start seeing extensions
of these methods
so the first extension we are going to
see is what happens when we
when we do not know psa when what
happens when
psa is not given
right so this is our first ah first
extension
and this corresponds to section three in
the notes you know learning a model for
an mdp
so here when we uh in reinforcement
learning
um you you when you
when you see the literature when you
read textbooks and and papers and so on
you will see this terminology called
model based versus model free
right so over here in in in this
terminology
model does not mean the model that we
are constructing right
so model over here refers to the model
of the environmental
model of the universe in which the agent
is operating right that is the model
that this is referring to
right and this essentially means your
model means
psa now if you know psa if you know how
uh what state you might end up in
depending on what action you took
it means you know how the environment
works right you know you have a model of
the environment that's what this model
means
right now psa is also called the model
and the uh the the first topic that
we're going to cover
is learning a model again
here by learning a model i mean learning
psa
so supposing we do not know how the
um how how i know how the transitions
work
we don't know what what state we might
end up with and supposing this
you know just assume psa is not given
what do we do
and when psa is not given the one
one thing that we can do is basically um
assuming we have some kind of you know
a simulator where you know we can we can
run these experiments
start run multiple trials
right run multiple trials where in each
step you start at some
some state s naught take a random action
you know
a naught you end up in s one
take another random action
s2
and so on and then repeat a trial
is not
and so on right so each horizontal
line corresponds to one trial
right in uh in the homework that you
will see that we'll be releasing on
monday so
you can think of each trial so so the
homework problem is about
balancing the cartwheel or the inverted
pendulum where
the goal is uh you're given um a stick
and you need
which is uh which has one degree of
freedom which can move around and it's
balanced on a cartwheel the cartwheel
also has one
degree of freedom and you need to keep
moving the cartwheel to keep the stick
balanced upright
right and a trial in such a case would
be starting at some
initial configuration an initial
position an initial angle of the stick
an initial
velocity of the cart and the actions in
that case would be to move the cart left
or move the move the cart right
right so take some random action
starting from some initial state
until you know the the the the stick
falls down or some such terminating
condition right
and then start over again with a
different starting
state and you know take different
actions you may be following some
particular policy you may be
taking random actions it does not matter
we are basically
exploring the environment we are
learning the environment right
and take some such actions like this and
then
construct
estimators for psa from this
so p i'm just going to call it p hat
s a of s prime is equal to
the number of times
number of times we took action a
at state
s and
got to
[Music]
state s prime over
number of times
we took
action a at
state s right
so run such trials lots and lots of them
and once once you run all these trials
we just count the number of times we
were at state
some particular s and took a particular
action a
and that goes into the denominator and
then
the number of times when we took that
action in that state
what what fraction of times did we
arrive at state s prime
right so this is the simple maximum
likelihood estimator
of ah the transition probabilities
right and it it might so happen that
sometimes both of this could
end up being 0 or 0. right we saw this
in in naive bayes when you are trying to
get maximum likelihood estimates based
on counts such as this
it may so happen that for some of the
cases we may we may have zero or zero
in those cases it is common to
you know a common practice in such cases
when we get 0 over 0
is to assume
a uniform a uniform distribution
for a p of s a which means uh if we have
never
reached the state s and taken an action
a from state s
just assume that we are you know that we
are going to we are going to
uniformly end up in any one of them now
the moment we
actually end up taking an action at
state s
we can then update our counts to reflect
what the the
actual uh the the actual
distribution was the moment we reach a
state s and perform an action a the
denominator is no longer 0 it will be 1
right and then we we won't have the 0
over 0.
until then you know it is common to
assume a uniform action
assume a uniform distribution over a few
future states
and using this this kind of an estimate
estimation of the of the states of the
transition probabilities
we can now construct an algorithm it
looks like this
so this is an algorithm
with model learning again here by model
i mean psa
the transition probabilities
right so
initialize pi
randomly
right now
to ah
repeat
execute pi
for some time
right which means basically
you know step one or two a rather
to a right so run a few trials
where the actions you are choosing are
based on the random initialization
of pi
b
yeah using
these trials
estimate
p hat of s a right and
by estimate p hat of s a basically ah
this means
estimate s times a number of probability
distribution where each distribution is
over all the future states
right this for
each s comma a right so there are
s times a number of such probability
distributions
so estimate all of them
and see
apply value iteration i am just going to
write it as v
i value iteration
using p hat sa
using p hat assay
to get
updated v
let's call it v v
and d
update phi
to be greedy
with respect to
vt right so what's this
algorithm telling us start at some
some random initialization of policy
some random policy
right and follow that policy for some
time
and by following this policy for for
some time basically what we are trying
to do
is uh not only learn
an estimate of our value function but we
are also
learning psa as well right by following
some some
policy we are learning how the
environment works you take some action
from a current state you end up in some
new new state
right and you keep observing that again
and again you tend to learn how the
world works you tend to learn
how the dynamics of the system works
right and that's like a
a separate task from estimating the
value function like right
learning how the dynamics of the
environment works is a separate task
from learning the value function
corresponding to that policy
right and using this experience we can
estimate p hat
assay it is important to note that
learning p hat s a is independent of the
policy that we were following
right and in fact what we can do is to
estimate p hat
s a in each iteration we can actually
use
the accumulated counts from all the
previous iterations as well
to get a better estimate of of the p hat
essays
right and using the estimated p hat
essay
we perform value iteration now what was
value iteration
in value iteration to
ah remind you this was value iteration
in value iteration we basically
loop ah you know so this enti this
line over here apply value iteration
means
perform this loop until convergence
right so step 2c is actually a full
loop of value iteration and in this
value iteration
we see that we need to take an
expectation
as part of computing value iteration and
it is for this
expectation where we use the p hat
essays instead of psas
we do don't know psa we are just
we are using data to uh construct an
estimate p hat essay and
you know it is this p hat essay
estimating this p hat essay that we call
as
learning a model right we use the
estimated dynamics of the environment
to cons to uh to perform value iteration
and reach some v star
so it is the v star of that particular
iteration
and the v star will change from
iteration to iteration of that algorithm
because we are using ah different
dynamics in each iteration
yes questions
yeah good question so the question is
why not just perform a and b
over and over until we are satisfied and
then do c and d
the reason why uh you know that might
not work all the time
is because unless you have a good policy
you may not even reach certain states
yeah so so so the question is uh we need
uh you know why not exhaustively search
uh sa uh
all the states and all the actions all
tuples and and the reason that might not
be possible in practice is because
uh we may not be able to arbitrarily
choose
an s of our choice right
we we we may be limited to start from
certain
starting initial states and explore by
taking actions
we may it may not be possible to say you
know i want to start at some particular
some particular state at some time and
to
to exhaustively try all possible s and a
sequences can be exponentially
you know complex it mean you may not be
able to do a brute force and do a full
sweep
that could take you know that could be
exponentially logical it could take
years for example right
to do a full sweep of the entire state
and action space
and that's why we we learn we
follow this iterative approach where we
where we um
try some try some initial trials for
some policy get an estimate
and then ah perform value iteration and
use that value iteration to drive the
exploration in the next day
right yes questions
say like we can use sub strings of it as
episodes right
like if you if you start from state one
one and then some
in the middle you go to state five four
and then the end state is nine
you can use like part of those episodes
so the question is can we use parts of
episodes as new episodes
and the answer is to to uh to calculate
this
we are only calculating you know these
links at a time
right we take s a and s prime
and count them to to estimate this
so when we are when we are estimating
the probabilities we take
all the episodes that we have and only
look at every consecutive
s a s prime triples
right so this is an algorithm that we
get where we are
simultaneously performing value
iteration and
also learning the dynamics of the system
so at this step
we will achieve the optimal value
function
assuming a certain given dynamics right
for this particular dynamics of p hat sa
that we have that we have learned the
resulting v at the end of one loop
of of of this algorithm will give us the
v star
corresponding to that p hat assay right
but that p hat s a might not be
the the correct dynamics of the system
because it is just
some kind of an estimate right and then
we use this
the resulting ah pi star
to go back and perform so get some more
experience
right run some motorized improve our p
hat essay
and then re-estimate the value iteration
now one obvious
optimization or computational
optimization is that
when we start the value iteration in
some in some loop
when when we describe value iteration we
would always start
the value function at zero so instead
what we can do is
for the next in the next iteration when
we start value iteration we can
initialize the value function at the
same point where we had converged in the
previous function instead of starting it
at 0 all the time
right and that will that will allow us
to have a much more faster
convergence in step c
any questions on this
good
yes question step d
so step d ah we you're saying you know
update pi to be
greedy with respect to vt and that is um
this uh step two you have you you get
some v
and you get the pi corresponding to that
v
so so value iteration and policy
iteration
they assume that we know the dynamics
right and when we do not know the
dynamics what what the exaction
transition probabilities are you know
you can think of that
as one relaxation of the mdp where we do
not know what the exact transition
probabilities is
and and that gives us this algorithm
this algorithm where we are
simultaneously
learning the dynamics learning the model
and also performing value iteration
according to the learned dynamics
next we will see another relaxation
which is thus far we have
limited our our study to cases
of or the types of mdp where the states
and the actions were discrete and finite
right we were limited to
finite state and finite actions now what
happens when
the states is continuous right what
happens if
the set of all possible states is is
continuous for example
in the inverted pendulum problem that
you will be seeing in your next preset
the the position of the pendulum which
which you are trying to maintain it
upright
the state of this the pendulum can be
represented by
the angle it makes from the angle it
makes from the horizontal ah
horizontal floor or the horizontal table
wherever it is placed right
and that angle is continuous right so
in in in in kind of reality
the state of the pendulum or the state
of your system or your agent
is continuous and what do we do in that
in such situations one obvious answer or
one simplistic approach is what is
called as discretization
in discretization the idea is pretty
simple
supposing our state so
assume that ah
this is the s space of say the inverted
pendulum problem so
as a reminder in the inverted pendulum
problem ah we have a cart
right that can move in along one
direction and on
on top of that we have a stick that you
are trying to balance
and the stick could you know tilt this
way or it could tilt this way
according to the dynamics of the system
right
and if it is tilting this way then we
want to have a policy
where we where we recognize that when
you know the
the angle is turned is is tilted to the
left
then we want to move the cart to the
left so the cart has actions
move left or move right like two actions
and the state can be you know any
possible
angle and any possible velocity any
possible position
of this of this card
right so assume we have
angle and
velocity right so this this space
represents the set of all states
that the system can be however
the algorithms that we have studied so
far are all designed for
finite state and finite actions right so
a common a common technique in in such
cases
is to discretize the
state space
into discrete parts
right so what used to be
a continuous problem by discretization
we can turn it into
a discrete problem or a discrete setting
and we generally have some kind of
a bound ah
on on on the on the state space for
example angles are kind of limited
between
you know 0 and 180 degrees so you know
there is a natural
boundary for even though it is
continuous there's a natural boundary
on on both sides and similarly the
velocity can be bounded between zero and
the maximum velocity the cart can go you
know
whatever 10 miles per hour some some
such thing right
and then we can discretize this state
space
into a discrete number of actual states
or the discrete number of um you know
virtual states that will be working with
this question
so the question is we could we can uh uh
limit this more using you know
domain knowledge like symmetry and
whatnot but that's not the point here
so uh the the the main the main concern
with uh such approaches which we're
coming to next is
um once we once we come up with
you know a discretized state s prime
or s hat which ah where s was continuous
and this is discrete so this is the
discretized version of
of s a common problem that we will see
is you know there are basically two
problems
so the first problem is
so the first problem is now what happens
so uh
let's let's let's kind of uh switch back
to
you know um supervised learning and
linear regression right let's let's uh
step away from reinforcement learning
for a brief moment
so if we had a data set like this
right what kind of a model would you try
to fit
supposing this x and this is y what kind
of a model would we try to fit
linear right so this this looks like a
perfect
um uh you know perfect textbook case of
a data set where linear regression would
work very well
right now in linear regression we would
just fit a straight line through this
however if we were to perform
discretization
and learn the the appropriate y value
within each
discrete unit we would get something
like this right
right which means now we are if if we ah
now discretize it into
into bins and take the average in each
bin to be the estimator for that bin
right that is essentially what we are
doing from moving from a
continuous state to a discrete state by
discretizing we would get a hypothesis
like this
however this is pretty bad because first
you know
it is much more complex right the number
of parameters we need is
the number of bins that we are breaking
down
breaking this down into and further we
are not getting any kind of
generalization
now what happens if our data set you
know had some examples here and some
examples here and we did not have any
examples here
right discretization would just not work
because we have never
we have never uh seen what what what's
uh what happens in this pen
so in these regions you know
we would have zero examples and
discretization is is a pretty bad thing
to do
ah in in such cases right instead we
would rather have
a simple straight line right
which uses a much smaller number of
parameters
and also it can interpolate well in
regions where we don't have a lot of
examples
right so this this this idea of
of having some kind of a fitted function
not only reduces the number of
parameters
that we need but we also get some amount
of generalization
into regions where we don't have a lot
of a lot of examples right
and that is the idea that we are going
to
look into next
so as far as your homework problem is
concerned
we will actually be solving it with
discretization
and that's because it's a simple problem
and that's you know um it's
uh the purpose of the homework is to is
to give you a framework to understand
uh value iteration and estimating
estimating
the transition probabilities etc however
in in larger problems in more complex
problems
discretization usually is
is not the first step that you can that
you use in
in um in in in some cases
you do use discretization but there you
would need to kind of
use some pre you you need to heavily use
the domain knowledge of the problem
space to reduce the dimensionality
right so with discretization
one problem is this this you know we
need to break it into multiple bins and
you know it does not generalize well the
other problem with discretization
is what is called as the curse of
dimensionality
which means suppose we have
suppose we have a state space of
you know let us call it 6
6 states so let us say we have things
like
the
yeah supposing it's you know
you're trying to learn learn a
helicopter then the number of states
that you have are like the x position y
position z position and and you know the
the uh angle at which the helicopter is
is um
is pointing to so it's like how upward
downward the uh helicopter is pointing
to
or you know um so you have three
different angles the the angle the the
angle at which the nose of the
helicopter is pointing the angle at
which it is
turned left or right and you know
there's one more angle
which i'm not familiar with flying
helicopters but
but anyway so you have a you know
different kinds of angles
and different velocities x
x y dot and z dot so what's the velocity
uh along the x axis what's the velocity
on the y axis what's the
velocity on the z axis and all the
angular velocity so
theta dot dot
psi dot and i think i'm just psi here
right
so 1 2 3 4 5 6 plus
6 so you have 12 you know 12 different
coordinates
in your state space and they're all
continuous right and if you were to
discretize them
right let's say you were to discretize
them into
where each thing into say 10 units right
you would you would essentially get
10 to the 12 number of discretized
states
right so each each
coordinate of your state space is
continuous and let's say you discretize
them into 10
into 10 units or 10 bins then the total
size of your state space is essentially
10 to the 12
right and that's pretty massive and
and it and it is this exactly this kind
of an explosion in states
that is ah that you get due to
discretization that is called the curse
of dimensionality
right and it is
and that is probably one of the biggest
limitations of discretization because
the number of states as you add the
number of components in your
in your state space it just just just
explodes
right and that brings us to what is
called as
the value function approximation
so in value function approximation we
we now want to to work in a setting
where s is continuous
s is
continuous and
we don't discretize
right and in this case
the most common setting is to have
something to have some kind of a
simulator
right so you have a simulator
and in this simulator accept some state
s
t some state
a t and you get s t
plus one right so assume you have some
kind of a stimulator
where it takes as input the current
state and the action
and outputs the next state right and
the the biggest difference between this
and
the previous ah model that we were
working with was that in the previous
model
we had a finite number of states right
and we had
a multinomial kind of a distribution
over the next state for every state and
action pair
but over here the number of states is
continuous
and we have in place of of
a multinomial kind of a model now i am
referring to
the collection psa as a collection of
multinomials
in place of a multinomial which work
well in the discrete setting
we instead have you know assume we have
some kind of a simulator
where we feed a real valued input and
some action
and you get output as some other real
valued state
all right and these simulators can be
you know um
are generally you know things like you
know physics simulators are commonly
used
if you are working in some kind of a
game playing scenario you know then the
game engine can itself is the simulator
and so on
right and now what you want to do is
ah basically try to do
the equivalent of this
in a continuous space right so you want
to kind of
transform this into a continuous setting
this worked well because we were just
counting
and it worked well because you know we
could count discrete things
however now we are in a continuous state
and counting does not work anymore
right and here we going to use
and here we are going to learn this
simulator
to the extent possible and what do i
mean by that what i mean by that is
we are going to make an assumption
that
s t plus 1 is equal to
some function of s t
a t right and this
relation
a common thing ah for example what we
could do
is assume f of uh
assume a linear form for this relation
which means
f is linear so a is t
plus b
a t where a is
a matrix and b is another matrix
and you can think of supposing
s is in let us say rd
now a is therefore in
r d by d
and similarly if a is in
r you know let's call it r or
r p then b
is in r d by p
right and for those of you who have you
know some background in
in electrical engineering you might
recognize this as a linear dynamic
system
right there is you have some particular
state and you are taking some action
and the action and the state
have this linear relationship to decide
the next state
right and assuming that your
your um that your environment has this
kind of
a linear dynamical relation we can then
uh do the equivalent thing of this
which is what should i raise
probably it is this
which is
follow some policy and
run against ah basically get some
experience against the simulator
s2 1.
and so on and another trial s
s 0 2
a naught 2 and so on
so what's happening here is these these
are trials that we are running according
to some policy
against the simulator right
and from this we collect
um s's and um these s
a s prime
triples so s a got us to s prime this is
one example
s and s a got us to on the next x prime
this is another example
and so on and we can
collect this data set of s
a s prime triples
and then define a loss function
j of a comma b
is equal to sum over i
equals one to n assuming we do
n trials
and just to make the math simple
assuming we are terminating
all of them at st
right after you take t time steps let's
assume we just terminated
and t equals
zero to t minus one
what we want to what we want to do is ah
minimize the square error between
s t plus 1 of i
minus a
s t of i plus
b a t
i
right so define a cost function
where the s t
plus 1 or the s prime
is considered the true or the y label
and this is your hypothesis
right so this s t plus 1 you think of
this as y
and this you think of it as um theta
and x where theta is a comma b and x
is s comma a all right
and now once you have a loss function
like this
you can solve it using gradient descent
and recover
a and b where a and b are the parameters
of this of this cost function
this question
so the question is is this can we think
of this as a policy because it takes s
and a and gives us the next state
so a policy takes as input at the
current state
and returns as output the action that we
need to take while we are in this
current state
right so this think of this as as the
dynamics of the system
right if you are in a current state and
you take an action according to some
policy
what is the new state that we're going
to end up with
right whereas a policy will tell us if
we are given
uh the current state s what should a be
that's the policy
so the question is are we not uh
concerned about policy
in in a continuous state the answer is
yes right now we are still in the state
where
we are doing something that is
equivalent to learning the model
and once we learn the model we will plug
it into some algorithm like this
where we learn the model and estimate
value and policies we are yet to
construct the
full algorithm we are only addressing
this part of the corresponding algorithm
of the continuous setting yes question
that's correct so first sum uh is across
trials
the second sum is within a trial
so the question is why is this a linear
a reasonable assumption
it may or may not be a reasonable
assumption uh this is just an example
of how if you model it as a and b as a
linear dynamical system
then you can have a cost function like
this and learn a
suitable um you know a suitable model
you can you can absolutely use a more
complex model over here and minimize
you know instead of a s t plus b a t you
would have a more complex form here
and you can minimize it that's totally
reasonable to do
we will uh at this point let us just
assume that our model can be represented
as a
linear system most a lot of lot of
a lot of examples can actually do pretty
well in this and we'll see
you know what some changes can be done
to this to actually you know work in
lot more cases shortly right
this question because
so the so the question is you know in a
continuous setting
uh should the action also be real valued
for the policy
it need not be so you can have
continuous states but still discrete
actions for example if you're trying to
balance a cart pole
your state can be continuous where you
know the states are angles and
velocities
but your action can still be discrete it
can be move left or move right
so you you can you can um yeah having
continuous state does not mean your
action also have to be
continuous in in cases when the action
is discrete and state is continuous your
policy will take
continuous input and output discrete
the policy because it's taking input
yes
[Music]
yes now policy will will uh uh will be
some kind of a
function yes so policy it uh so so
one thing to notice should a policy
always be
a function so if you see this relation
over here
so what you do in um
so the policy if you think of it as
something in this form
right the induced policy according to
some v then it need not actually have
any particular functional form right it
can just
evaluate the v function which takes a
continuous input
at at different possible
according to different possible actions
right
and you can get the the next state
according to the dynamical system that
we
that we constructed right and evaluate
the value function at the new states
and you can just take the arg max
right so so the policy can be
kind of implicit or induced according to
some value function and some model it
need not always be an explicit
functional form
all right so then if we
minimize this cost so a hat comma b
hat equals argument
of a comma b then a hat and b hat
will be our learned model by again by
model i mean
the you know what we have learned about
the way the world works
this a hat and b hat is you can think of
it as the equivalent
of p hat assay
right so p hat sa gave us a way to
relate state and action to the next
state and here a hat b hat
gives us a way to relate state and
action to the next state
this question
um
right so the model that we learnt with
the linear model that we learned
is was deterministic in some sense
that s t
plus 1 is equal to
a hat s t
plus b hat
a t right so once we minimize a hat and
b hat
according to this according to this
this uh cost function we will recover
some a hat and b hat
and the the prediction that we are going
to make for the next state
is according to this right but in
general so so if we just limit ourselves
to this
we would call this a deterministic model
right but in reality it's always a good
idea to have
to ah to have some kind of stochasticity
in
in your model which means we want to
estimate
we want to predict s t plus one
equal to a hat
st plus b hat
a t
plus some epsilon
right where epsilon comes from
you know a common choice is a normal
distribution that has mean 0
and some covariance sigma and it's also
possible
to learn this sigma from data
basically the way to think of this
covariance is to
you can you can estimate this covariance
as 1 over n
times 1 over
t minus 1.
s t
s i t plus 1
minus a
s k i plus
b t i
right so this is just the if you know
you you've done this with gda you'll put
you know this is something you should be
familiar with
which is the maximum likelihood estimate
of a covariance
it will be just the uh residual residual
transpose
uh across all the examples this question
because this is uh we're summing across
all
n and t right
right so it is um in general
it is considered a good practice to
build stochastic models
where the prediction that we make about
the next state
is follows this format
where for each prediction we sample
an epsilon according to this
distribution
and this distribution is learned where
the covariance
is estimated this way so you can think
of sigma hat as this
next question
so the question is for the pset we you
know um
you will not be doing any of this for
the pset right in general
the the question is uh you know when
when do we know we have collected enough
evidence
uh or our experience when this
in case of the discrete uh setting you
can
you know stop when the v stars that you
get at the end of each iteration starts
converging
so the question is you know you can you
can phrase the same question as when do
you know you have
your estimate of p hat sa is sufficient
you know which is the same as when
when is the estimate of a and b you know
sufficiently correct
and in this case uh you can consider it
as sufficient when
this overall you know this outer loop
converges
yeah so uh again so for the piece that
we have instructions given in the pset
itself you can follow those instructions
and and uh the idea in general is that
your
your your value function stops changing
over time right that's that's a good
sign
right so um instead of constructing a
deterministic model
you can it is always better to construct
a stochastic model where
the noise that you want to induce into
the stochastic system
can also be estimated using using mle
right a and b were estimated using mle
and then we can also estimate the noise
that we want to induce
which is kind of consistent with the the
uh
with the errors that you are making can
also be learnt this way
and when you are making a next
prediction you know just sample some
noise according to
that covariance and make your you know a
noisy prediction every time
so this is how we would learn a model
so
learn a model in
continuous setting
right now let us
now now let us see after having
addressed
uh modeling the the uh
modeling the environment itself is
continuous now what do we do about the
value function itself because
if you remember um
if you remember for example in this
example
s comes up in in the model in the in the
transition
and s comes as an input to v right in
the discrete setting
v was just an array where we had
as the length of the array equal to the
number of states that we had and the
transition
function or the or the environment was
also a matrix
where the number of states was
continuous so it was just a matrix
but now when we move to continuous
states
the transitions or the or the
environment or the model
you know can be made continuous next we
need to make
the value function also continuous
right and a common approach for ah
for doing that is to first think of our
think of our value function as
you know v of s is equal to
r of s plus gamma times
gamma times
max a
expectation of s prime from
psa
v s prime
now p s a
you can think of psa from you know this
ah
model as p s a
is equal to some normal distribution
where the mean
is a s
plus b a
and covariance is the
covariance that we estimated here
so you can think of this as psa where
you sample the next state according to
this and and so this can now
you can think of it as r of s
plus gamma times max
a integral
p of
psa of s prime
times v
[Music]
of s prime d s prime
right this is the gaussian pdf
right so you can think of the value
function as this analog of
of of the discrete version
where the expectation is now over
a continuous random variable instead of
a discrete random variable
right and the input to the value
function is also a continuous
continuous value right and
this identity is is you know is again
is also called the bellman equation
because it's
bellman equation it is just the
continuous version of the discrete
setting
however what we end up doing in practice
is to use what is called as a
fitted value function or the value
function approximation
value function approximation where we
say v
of s is equal to you know for example
in this case let us assume a
simple theta transpose phi of s
right just like linear regression with
some kind of a feature map you construct
a feature map of your state space
using you know whatever domain knowledge
you have and assume you have
some kind of a linear relationship
for ah for the for the value of a
function based on the state that it is
that it's in right and
with this assumption
what we what we want to do is
try to come up with a value function
a v function that has this form but
satisfies the bellman equation right
which is basically what we did with with
the value iteration in the discrete case
and we're going to now do the same thing
with the continuous in the continuous
case
right so this gives us an algorithm
with these two assumptions that looks
like this
you
so now this is an algorithm
where we are using
continuous state
with you know some model
where the model in this you know you can
assume it to be a linear dynamical
system with you know
where you have the a and b matrices and
here is you
you're doing value
function approximation
right so here this was s
t plus 1 equals a
s t plus
b a t the value function approximation
where we have v
of s is equal to theta transpose
phi of s so this algorithm
is basically an adaptation of this
algorithm
but to the setting of of continuous
states
and value function approximation right
over here
both the states and the value functions
you can you can think of them as
non-parametric which means we did not
have a family of
um some kind of a family of functions
for
v or psa however these
are parametric in the sense that the
transition or the model has a and b as
the parameters
or if you are having epsilon it has
sigma is also a parameter
and the value function has theta as the
parameter
right so it is basically an adaptation
of that algorithm into the setting
so step one
randomly
sample n
states call them
s 1 s 2
s n n s
to
initialize theta
to be 0 and step 3
repeat until convergence
now there is an inner loop here for
i equals one till n
the inner loop
is there a question so
for i equals one through n
oh sorry there is an inner loop within
this as well
for
each a
in the action space
sample
s1 prime till
sk prime from
p s
i a right
so in this case it could be for example
um
you know the normal distribution with a
s i plus
b a and covariance sigma hat for example
and then set
qa
is equal to the average 1 over k
right j equals 1 through k
r of s i
plus gamma of
v of s
j prime again
where here v of
s is equal to theta transpose
v of s
right so we do this for each action
and then continue it over here
set y i equals
max a q of a
and that ends this so
let us call this as a start a
start b and start c so this is finish
c this is finish
b
and then
set theta hat
equals arc
min theta from
i equals 1 to n
theta transpose phi of
s i minus
y i square
this this is finish a right so
start a ends with finish a and start b
ends with finish b and start c ends with
finish c
right so what's happening here
first we start by initializing the the
theta of our
value function class to be some
to some value you know theta equals 0
and then we repeat
this iteration over and over where first
for each example our goal is
for each
i in
yeah so for ah
for each of the states that we have
sampled randomly
we want to ah we want to come up with an
estimate
y i for each s i
right that is the goal here of the outer
loop
so for each of the states that we have
sampled
we want to come up with ah y i
which is our think of y
i as the
[Music]
label for v of
s i
right so we want to construct
an estimate of v of s i
for each i and that is what the
the start v to end b achieves
and the way we go about doing that is
for
at each uh for each s i
take all the possible actions starting
from
s i and for each action
we sample k next states so for each
si and action we get k number of next
states
sample according to the transition right
and this transition we are going to use
the learnt model it could be a linear
dynamical system it could be
you know anything more complex
and then we are going to define this
quantity q of a
as the expected value
of taking that action from that state
right so q of a
is the average of r of s i plus
gamma of v of the next state
and average across all the js
right does it make sense so we're going
to take you're going to start with some
some random state s
and from this s we're going to take all
the possible actions a
a1 a2
a in this case you know capital a we're
going to take all the possible actions
from each
state and for each action that we take
we are going to get k number of s prime
so f prime 1 until
s prime k for each action
right and similarly get s prime
1 until s prime k for each action for
each state
right and then from each of those
final states you are going to evaluate
the value according to
the current estimate of the v function
right so the current estimate of the v
function uses
the theta value we have so far right in
the first iteration it is going to be 0
after that is going to be something else
right according to the current estimate
of the of the v function
we're going to estimate the the uh we're
going to use the
evaluation of these states
using the current estimate of the value
function and we're going to
construct this q value
as the
as the expected value
of taking this action
this function yes questions
yes so fee of s
is is just a feature map and you define
fee of s according to your problem
setting right so
in in homework one we define feature
maps with sinusoidal squared
polynomials etcetera you define some
such feature map for your state space
this question can you explain that
i'll come to that for now assume v has
this linear relationship
right so what we do is for each s we
take all the possible actions
and from each possible action you know
sample new states
and for each of those new states
calculate the value
of the each new state according to
the value function approximation that we
have
right and then take the average and this
q is now an approximation for
right so q is therefore an approximation
q of um
q of a is therefore approximately
r of s i
plus gamma times expectation
of s prime and q
[Music]
sorry s prime of p s a
of v of s prime
right so the q value that we constructed
is
an exp is is approximately this and the
reason is because
so r is just a constant so you can
actually take out r
from this averaging right and what
remains here
you know this what we are seeing here is
therefore a monte carlo
estimate of this expectation right it is
a monte carlo expectation because
we are approximating the transition
with k items and
it is also an approximation of v because
we are only using the current estimate
of
uh of the v of the value function with
this functional form
yes
expected long term value for taking
from from this uh state for taking
action a
so shouldn't you be yeah so you can
think of it as q of s comma a that's
point two
so yeah q of s prime
right that's fine so right so this q is
an approximation
of
of the right hand side of the of the
of the right hand side of the bellman
equation right
so now we define y i
as the max over q i so y i
is now max
a of q i of of q a
and q a is basically um
r of s i plus
max a of gamma times
gamma times the expectation of s prime
from
psa of
v s y
right so y i which was max over q a is
max over you know max with respect to a
of this thing
and therefore it is you know when we
apply the max
r comes out of the max because there is
no a term in it and it is max
over a of this term right and this
now looks like the bellman update
operator right
or the bellman backup operator
so according to the bellman backup
operator
we should have one set v of
s to be equal to this
right but our v takes this
parametric form so we just cannot set v
of s to be some value
right because v is not an array and we
are not setting the s
element to be some value what we instead
want to do because we are in this
value function setting is to minimize
the distance between y i
and v of s i and that's exactly what
we're going to do we're going to
minimize the distance between y
y i and v of s i
this question
v is not a vector because s is
continuous we are in the continuous
setting
and we are you know we are we are
approximating the this continuous
function with this
linear form
of s is just a feature map for you know
some s
so um the way to to think about this is
to see the similarity with the bellman
backup operator
right in case of the bellman backup
operator we would have v of s i
to be equal to r of s i plus max of a
over this
expectation of v of s prime
instead because we are in the in this
you know
fitted value fitted function setting we
are going to
approximate this expectation with the
monte carlo expectation
that is you know this is the monte carlo
expectation
so this this expectation is going to
come in here
r phase sizes r of s i and this will
evaluate to some y of s
i which in the discrete setting we would
have just set it
as the ah as the width element or the s
element of the v
array but instead we are in you know a
fitted function setting which means we
want v of s to evaluate to y
or as close to y as possible right which
is why we minimize the squared error
between phi of
v so think of this as v of s i
right and this is the rhs
of the bellman backup operator
right so what is happening here um
is that first of all
let's see the sim uh a few things you
know the way it is
similar to this so first of all
here we are in in the discrete setting
we were learning both the model
and performing value iteration kind of
intertwined
and we are trying to do something
similar here in the sense
we are first
in this setting we are we are learning
the a's and b's the dynamics
which is equivalent to this first
we are not doing it uh intertwined but
we are first learning the dynamics
and using those dynamics we are now
performing
value iteration using the bellman backup
operator
but we are performing it in such a way
that the
the bellman backup operator is working
with these fitted value functions
right instead of the ah true value
functions
and another way to kind of understand
this better is
right if you remember value iteration
so s one through whatever s
plus d right in the in the uh fitted in
in the in the discrete setting we had
you know supposing this was v star
right you start with some you know
random initialization v naught
and apply the bellman backup operator to
get
v1 and we would keep getting closer to
closer and closer
right where each hop was
one application of the bellman backup
operator
and the bellman backup operator was a
contraction mapping so no matter where
you started you would converge at v star
but now in this setting this
the space of value functions is somewhat
limited we are limiting ourselves
to only those that can be expressed as a
linear combination
of the feature maps of s which means
this whole algorithm
is kind of limited to some
set of
you know think of this as
set of all v
which can be you know such that v of
s equals theta transpose
phi of s right
this family of functions cannot
represent all the possible
functions in this functional space right
so we kind of limited in that sense
and when we if we start with some value
function over here
and we apply one iteration of this
fitted value
algorithm fitted value or iteration
it will give us ah so let me
so if we are over here let us call this
v of t the fitted value iteration
might give us y i such that
y i is over here that it might be
outside our
functional space the set of y i's right
so
we ideally want v of s
i to be equal to y i right we want v of
s i to be equal to i
we want this to be 0 right but this
y may be outside our our ah
our functional space and therefore when
we perform this minimization
we are going to get the nearest the
projection of
y i onto this subspace right that's
that's exactly you know the
what what happened in linear regression
we are going to get this function
over here which is the projection of y
onto this
onto the space the nearest point in our
family of functions that is nearest y
right and then we're probably
going to keep hopping you know by by
keeping ourselves within
the family of of the v functions
of this parametric space that we have
defined
and get as close as possible to v star
right that's what this
this algorithm will do us this algorithm
does not have
the convergence guarantees of
the discrete space setting in the
discrete space setting
the bellman backup operator would take
us to the true v star after a certain
number of
uh trials whereas in the fitted value
functions
we have limited ourselves to some space
and v star might be out of this space
there's no guarantee and there is no
guarantee that this algorithm
will converge but in practice it seems
you know it generally tends to work well
next question
so think of this as some kind of a
functional space don't think of this as
as
you know um yeah just think of it as
some
functional space where the the set of
all functions that can be defined in
this form
is is limited to some kind of a set
by coming up with better features yeah
i'm coming to that next yeah man
yeah so uh your v star can be outside
the set of all
uh functions yes question
yes here we are still assuming actions
are discrete because we are performing a
max
over the different q a's we are still
assuming actions are discrete good
questions
the fact that we are minimizing this you
know think of this as the
resulting theta transpose s i after
minimizing this
um after minimizing this squared error
the result you know once you do this so
v hat of s is equal to theta hat
of phi of s so this
is essentially the projection of y on to
the nearest point in the function space
why are we not using ps such that it
belongs to that space because
yeah so the question is uh yeah that's
that's that's uh something i'm coming
uh uh going to address next right
so uh there are
there are there are um we we've seen two
kind of
uh extensions to the standard policy
iteration and
value iteration so far one extension was
when we don't know the model when we
don't know the
the transition uh probabilities we
estimate it from data
right psa and the other extension that
we saw was to move on to this
continuous setting from discrete setting
and once we move into continuous setting
the number of parameters we have can
potentially be infinite
and therefore we limit ourselves limit
our expressivity to
some kind of parametric family model
right and once we are in limited to this
to this parametric family
of of value functions which we call as
value function approximation
we then define an algorithm which is
you know kind of similar in spirit to
the value iteration
right it is similar in spirit because we
are performing the same kind of updates
except when we are in in the in the
value iteration we could just set the
the value that v of s needed to evaluate
to
however in the because we are now
limited to
a parametric family what we do is
minimize the loss between
um what what our hypothesis can predict
and what the right answer should be
right now there are um you know based on
these two extensions
we can um so this this may
basically kind of ah marks the end of
what's kind of in syllabus
let's see how we can you know some of
the other concepts in reinforcement
learning and
how you can think of the other concepts
that you may come across
as extensions to what we have seen so
far
right so in reinforcement learning
in the in the broader space right
we can think of two approaches in
general
the two approaches are
approaches based on value functions and
approaches based on
policies so
value function based approaches
versus policy based
right so in the simplest setting right
in
when everything is discrete and finite
it is basically the value iteration and
the policy based approach
is basically the policy iteration
right and as we move on to more
as we move on in terms of the complexity
hierarchy
when we move on to infinite space
infinite state space
we get the fitted value iteration
so fitted value iteration is basically
this algorithm that we saw
right and
in both these algorithms we call both
these algorithms
as model based algorithms we call them
model based algorithms because
we explicit we constructed explicit
versions
of the way we believe that the model
works right
it was either in the form of the psa
transition matrix
or it was in the form of this linear
dynamical system
where s s t plus 1 was
distributed according to a normal
equation
right either we constructed a dynamical
system approximation of the
of the model or we used um you know
directly the psa transition matrix for
the
finite finite state case right however
we can move on to you know model free
methods
in the model free methods right we
acknowledge that we do not know how the
model ah how the real world works or the
how the dynamics of the system works
but we also say we do not care how it
works whereas in model based approaches
we acknowledge that we didn't know
and we tried to learn it right in model
free approaches we say we don't know how
the how the uh
how the world works we don't know how
the transitions happen and we don't care
and the way we say we don't care is by
coming up with what is called as
a q function right
and the q function is basically think of
it as
you know q of s a
to be the value
the expected value of being in state s
and taking an action a
right and the reason why you know
even though it seems like a simple
addition of an action
it is fundamentally very different the
reason why it's very different is
because supposing we learnt
you know v star of s and we don't know
how the
dynamics of the system works but we
still somehow figured out
the optimal value of being in each
being in for some state now how do we
decide what the action is
there's no way because we don't know
which state we will end up in by taking
some action because we don't know how
the dynamics of the system works
right so knowing v star is insufficient
if you don't know the dynamics of the
system
and the way we go about go about that
limitation
is to instead learn these q functions
which are which is basically
the q function is basically telling us
what is the expected
sum of all future rewards discounted sum
of future rewards
if we are at state s and taken action a
we don't know what set we are going to
end up in but if you take this action
from the state
you know the q of s a tells us what is
the expected sum of future rewards
right we just stay agnostic to which
state we are going to end up in
and directly assign a value to taking an
action at a given state
right and these techniques are called q
learning
and we can apply q learning a function
approximation to q learning as well
we saw function approximation applied to
value functions
and just just in a very similar way you
can we can perform
function approximation for q values or
or for the q function right
and um we saw an example where the
family of of of of the
function space with which we performed
approximation was linear
but there is nothing stopping us from
using more complex functions right
so this
right so this approximation of the value
function using a linear function
this could have been something much more
complex we could have used a neural
network here
where the input was s and the output was
the value at the last layer
and in in when we are minimizing this
you know use back propagation and
minimize the loss with respect to you
know the the parameters of a neural
network
right there is nothing that stopped us
from doing it and
when we use neural networks as the
function approximators for either the
value function or the q
function that basically gives us the
field of d parallel
or deep reinforcement learning so you
can use deep reinforcement learning
by using neural networks as
approximators for your value function or
the q function
there is another
there are there are other approaches you
you or other kinds of classifications
you can think of
um in the finite case the way we
evaluated the value function was using
something called as
exact method so the bellman backup
operator when you apply it over and over
again you get the exact
v star and there are other approaches
where we can either you can use
markov chains or monte carlo approaches
not my culture monte carlo approaches
or you can use something called as td
learning or temporal difference learning
td learning uh so in in monte carlo
approaches what we do is
we take some value we take some policy
and just follow that policy
until the end until we reach a
terminating state
and then average and then calculate the
discounted sum of rewards
and use that as the as the estimate of
the value function
that is actually try it out and measure
how much total value you got
and average it across multiple runs
that's that's a monte carlo based
however the limitation with that is that
you've got to follow the policy until
things terminate right whereas there is
there's something called tdd
learning or temporal difference learning
that is something in between exact and
monte carlo and in fact in practice td
learning is what's used most commonly
right if you're using uh
so td learning is in fact something very
similar to this right what we did over
here
is something very similar to td learning
that's td learning means temporal
difference learning
that's probably all that uh
i wanted to uh so there's there's
probably one more thing i want to say so
there is another another kind of um
line of line of of classification you
can
use for a reinforcement learning
algorithm there's something called
on policy
versus off policy
methods so in on policy methods you're
trying to learn the value function
by staying on the given policy whereas
with off policy
you know you're looking at data that was
that was where the the
uh trajectories were were obtained from
some other policy and you
you tried to learn the value function of
a new policy that you're trying to come
up with
and this off policy method has you know
for those of you who have a more
statistical background off policy
methods and reinforcement
reinforcement learning has a strong
connection to causal inference
right because in causal inference you
are seeing some observational data and
you are trying to
to work your way backwards to decide you
know what would have happened if we had
taken some other action instead
right and and that's that has uh kind of
a
pretty strong ties to causal inference
where uh here we are you know observing
a sequence of
actions that were taken according to
some policy and we are trying to answer
what would have happened if you tried
some other policy instead
right so reinforcement learning is uh is
is a vast
area of machine learning and in fact
probably reinforcement learning has its
roots
um in you know in in mostly in
in the field of electrical engineering
called um
optimal control and i think it you know
its history is probably older than
machine learning yeah in general and so
it's it's a pretty vast field
and there are lots of ways in which you
can use machine learning and the most
common way or the most popular way where
machine learning and reinforcement
learning are kind of
coming together is using is is using
more expressive
function approximation methods to
approximate either the value function or
the q function using neural networks or
deep learning techniques
and also there is um it's you can also
use neural networks for
you know policy based methods for
something called policy iteration though
you know we didn't cover any of that
in this course all right so that brings
us to an end to
uh reinforcement learning and starting
monday we will start
the next chapter which is unsupervised
learning right have a good weekend
you